8h30 la cloche sonne à l'école primaire
de la pointe des châteaux à saint leu
les élèves de l'unité d'enseignement
entre en classe
ces enfants sont concernés par le
handicap mental
dans cette classe spécialisée ils sont
encadrés par une professeur des écoles
tu es une équipe médico social de
l'institut médico pédagogique de
l'association claire joie c'est
spécifique a eu lieu l'unité
d'enseignement clairjoie il ya des
éducateurs dans la classe et en fait on
se partage les enfants sont tantôt avec
moi tant tout avec avec les éducatrices
le but de l'enseignement spécialisé
c'est de trouver les points forts de
l'enfant de les valoriser
ne jamais mettre les enfants en échec le
toujours cherché le bon côté des choses
pour qu'il se sente bien et qui
progresse et si un enfant ne peut pas il
peut pas trop bouger sa main et là on va
pas forcer pour qu'ils bougent sa main
on va trouver soit un substitut soit on
va essayer de l'imiter
les cris pour valoriser morale etc
aujourd'hui c'est mercredi la moitié de
la classe prend la route direction le
club de saint paul pour une activité
ludique et pédagogique nous trampoline
bon c'est la journée comme ça
ça te plaît
l'écho
le trampoline est un projet initié par
la psychomotricienne de l'association
clairjoie l'objectif est d'abord de
développer les aptitudes physiques et
mentales font aussi faire les appuis de
la terrestre
donc il ya un autre équilibre qui se met
en place et l'a donc l'enfant est obligé
d'adapter sa force sa posture
sinon ils tombent donc ça nous permet
aussi donc de faire cet ajustement là de
manière plaisante le dic
s'il n'y a pas de contrainte et il va
vraiment cherché à faire des efforts à
progresser et voilà c'est vraiment ce
très stimulant pour lui deuxième
objectif pour cette rentrée scolaire
amorcé la rencontre avec les enfants
dits ordinaires pour un échange qui se
développera tout au long de l'année
scolaire
là aujourd'hui comme c'était le premier
jour d de tous
on n'a pas fait trop d'échangés
on a vu d'autre à côté bouger l'autre on
a vu ce qu'il était capable de faire
on n'a pas fait des changements au fur
et à mesure on va échanger on va se
regarder on va se confronter qui est là
c'est vrai que pour évoluer ses boxeurs
se fera tout au long de l'année voilà
tout au long de l'année pour les parents
de ces enfants dits ordinaires
cette rencontre est vraiment bienvenu ça
lui apprendra côtoyer tous types de
personnes peut-être même se sentir à se
sentir
une mission pas d'aidé de partager et
c'est très bien pendant très bon ça
favorise la cohésion donc ça permet à un
enfant de connaître aussi et comme ça
ils voient aussi il se rend compte de ce
que c'est qu'un handicap
pourquoi il est entre guillemets est
différent même si au final son patron
parce que ce sont les mêmes elle
s'appelle thomas y est elle est dans le
groupe de mon petit fils
allons donc lui il aime bien la fille et
la fille lui aime aussi pareil donc ils
sont tombés à midi par l'ip cinq hommes
c'est une enfant handicapée peut pas
discuter avec elle mais si possible que
tous les deux sont en de bien ça y est
encore long pour nous il n'y a pas de
souci de ce côté là de leur côté les
enfants de lieux apprécie tout autant
pendant ce temps là bas
j'ai vu ce qu'ils ont fait hier le dépôt
tous les mercredis en d'aller voir
quelques faits contente de faire du
trampoline avec les enfants là bas
oui oui après on a fait chacun son tour
et après
les latences il on se tait c'est l'heure
du retour dans l'ensemble de l'école ici
les enfants se connaissent
l'apprentissage de la différence
s'effectue chaque joute c'est à l'école
d'apporter les réponses adéquates à peu
payés en fonction les possibilités des
potentialités des élèves donc il a
effectivement certains sont tellement
d'autres qui ont des déficiences
mentales mais c'est à nous adultes
éducateurs d'apporter des réponses pour
l'équipe éducative bien entendu c'est un
travail supplémentaire c'est pas anodin
veut dire que si chacun fait un pas vers
l'autre on peut espérer on peut espérer
avoir une société un petit peu plus
juste plus équitable et que et surtout
plus harmonieuse et c'est un petit peu
la finalité de l'école enfin si un
enfant est heureux à l'école ça a
conditionné bien entendu sa vie d'adulte
futur et on peut espérer avoir un adulte
épanoui
du pouvoir
mais